das könnte bahn brechen werden das space
experiment am forschungszentrum cern in
genf denn ihr könnten die beiden größten
rätsel der physik auf einmal gelöst
werden es geht um die alles
entscheidende frage hängen die
mysteriöse dunkle materie und die
antimaterie zusammen erstmalig wird in
diesem experiment nämlich getestet ob
dunkle materie auf antiteilchen anders
wirkt als auf normale materie kriegs und
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es ist nicht nur die dunkle
materie die fachleuten weltweit den
schlaf raubt denn wie kann es sein dass
sie trotz intensiver suche nicht
aufgespürt werden kann und das obwohl
sie entscheidend für wohl alles ist was
überhaupt existiert doch sie ist
unsichtbar sie sendet weder licht aus
noch reflektiert sie dieses und ihr
direkter nachweis steht so bis heute aus
immer wieder berichten wir hier bei
pixum science fiction über die dunkle
materie und ihre natur denn es gibt
viele mögliche kandidaten sind es die
leichten aktionen die sterilen neutrinos
die schweren vims oder sims oder gar die
dunklen photonen doch die dunkle materie
ist nicht die einzige rätselhafte
materie sorte auch die antimaterie ist
in diesem zusammenhang ganz vorne mit
dabei und auch über dieses rätsel haben
wir hier schon oft berichtet doch trotz
intensiver forschung konnte immer noch
nicht geklärt werden warum in unserem
heutigen kosmos mehr materie als
antimaterie vorhanden ist ein riesiges
rätsel der physik denn beim urknall muss
von beiden materie sorten eigentlich
gleich viel entstanden sein
ein neues experiment am cern könnte
jetzt für den entscheidenden durchbruch
sorgen und direkt beide rätsel auf
einmal lüften denn die forschungsteams
der europäischen organisation für
kernforschung in genf bringen erstmalig
beide themen zusammen das experiment
heißt mario nanni marion symmetry
experiment kurz gesagt sollen antiproton
ihr als detektor für dunkle materie
dienen dazu der physiker christians
moral
bisher haben wissenschaftler in
präzisions experimenten main
niedrigen energien stets materie
basierte proben genutzt um an ihnen eine
kopplung von dunkler materie
nachzuweisen wir suchen zum ersten mal
explizit nach einer wechselwirkung
zwischen dunkler materie und antimaterie
denn wenn die dunkle materie auf
antimaterie anders wirkt als auf normale
materie wäre dies ein entscheidender
hinweis auf die lange gesuchte
asymmetrie daraus wären dann spannende
rückschlüsse auf die dunkle materie
möglich denn das krasse in den meisten
studien wird einfach davon ausgegangen
dass es eine symmetrische wechselwirkung
der dunklen materie mit teilchen und
antiteilchen gibt also noch mal ganz
kurz antiteilchen die sind quasi anders
geladen als als unsere herkömmlichen
materie
das heißt ein elektron ist dort ein
positronen und positiv geladen und
protonen sind dort eben negativ geladen
doch das aktuelle experiment überprüft
nun ob das tatsächlich der fall ist in
ihrem experiment nutzen die fachleute
dafür antiprotonen diamanti proton dsl
array des herz erzeugt werden und allein
das ist schon eine besonderheit denn
hierbei handelt es sich um die einzige
forschungsanlage weltweit die in der
lage ist antiprotonen bei niedriger
energie zur verfügung zu stehen
ein einzelnes antiproton wird dann in
einer magnetischen penning falle
eingeschlossen durch die einwirkung
eines magneten kommt es dazu dass die
einzelnen gefangenen antiprotonen seinen
spin ändern denn jedes teilchen hat ja
so einen definierten spin heißt also
dass seine eigenen rotation umklappt und
zwar in regelmäßigen zyklen in der
fachsprache ist von einer so genannten
rezession die rede entscheidend hierbei
ist die frequenz also wie schnell dieses
umklappen der eigenen rotation abläuft
dazu christian maurer der an dem projekt
beteiligt ist die anwesenheit von
dunkler materie könnten wir dadurch den
diktieren dass sich diese frequenz
verändert dabei betrachten wir die
potenziellen teilchen der dunklen
materie als klassisches feld mit einer
bestimmten wellenlänge
diese wellen laufen kontinuierlich durch
unser experiment und verändern dort
periode die eigentlich konstante
präzisions frequenzen
die proton spins im magnetfeld heißt
also die präzession der antiproton spins
könnte in diesem experiment den
entscheidenden hinweis liefern nämlich
darauf dass die dunkle materie stärker
auf die antimaterie ein wirkt als auf
die gewöhnliche materie für die
fachleute ließe dass zwei sehr
bedeutsame rückschlüsse zu denn dann
wäre zum einen nichts geringeres als die
langgesuchte asymmetrie aufgespürt doch
nicht nur das denn das experiment könnte
zum anderen auch noch exakte messwerte
liefern und die wiederum könnten
entscheidende hinweise auf diejenigen
teilchen zu lassen aus denen die dunkle
materie besteht das bislang sehr weiter
kandidatenfeld könnte dadurch zumindest
eingegrenzt werden wenn masse und
energie der bislang unbekannten dunkle
materie teilchen näher bestimmt werden
könnten heisst also im klartext das
experiment ist ein großer
hoffnungsträger für die gesamte physik
welt und erste tests wurden bereits
durchgeführt doch bislang gab es noch
keine hinweise auf die dunkle materie
dabei wurde aber auch nur ein ganz
bestimmter frequenzbereich analysiert
und die fachleute sind durchaus
optimistisch gestimmt dazu stefan ulmer
vom base projekt mit unserem aktuellen
messaufbau haben wir zwar keine
signifikante und periodische änderung
der spins präzisions frequenz an die
profunden gleichwohl haben wir die
empfindlichkeit im vergleich zu
astrophysikalischen beobachtung um bis
zu 5 größenordnung übertroffen
das bedeutet wir haben basierend auf der
jetzigen empfindlichkeit unseres
experiments eine neue obere grenze für
die stärke einer potenziellen
wechselwirkung zwischen dunkler materie
und antimaterie definiert von den
vorstand am cern liegt also noch ein
langer weg und sehr viel arbeit auf dem
plan steht beispielsweise die messungen
noch empfindlicher zu gestalten um das
zu ermöglichen sollen beispielsweise
neue kühlmethoden für protonen und
antiprotonen entwickelt werden zudem
sind auch weitere studien angedacht in
denen andere antiteilchen eingesetzt
werden zum beispiel positronen und anti
millionen es bleibt also spannend mehr
zu anti materie auf der suche nach der
anti welt sehr fundiertes video hier wie
immer war hyperraum tv also anklicken
anschauen und unbedingt über raum tv
abonnieren
das ist ja hier auf youtube kostenlos
also bis dann bleibt dran